esto que está a mis espaldas es una
rueda de prensa organizada en un lugar
de la provincia de sumi en un Rango de
50 kilómetros de distancia más o menos
de la frontera y hasta aquí hemos venido
a encontrarnos con integrantes de Los
dos grupos que esta semana ingresaron en
Rusia en la región de volvorot en
general se puede decir que no hubo
resistencia se puede decir que la
resistencia fue nula o periódica pudimos
comprobar como la frontera no estaba
protegida correctamente las fuerzas que
la están protegiendo definitivamente no
estaban listas para morir por el régimen
de Putin los ucranianos nos apoyan con
medicinas gasolina y obviamente con
mucho ánimo respecto a planeación
podemos Consultar con ellos por ejemplo
les decimos que esto puede ser buen
ataque allí y aquí les preguntamos Qué
piensan qué puede ser posible Así que
podemos Consultar con ellos
la causa común es la libertad de Ucrania
la segunda fase posiblemente la tengamos
que hacer solos luchando en territorio
ruso estos hombres aseguran que
están de regreso a Ucrania sin ninguna
pérdida como asegura el gobierno de
Moscú hemos regresado hoy
los dos grupos y no tenemos bajos
usted puede llamarme neonazi puede
llamarme como quiera qué puedo hacer yo
tengo mi manera de pensar mi punto de
vista patriota mi punto de vista
tradicional de extrema derecha pero
nunca me verá alzando una bandera con
esvástica nunca me verá levantando la
mano en signo de Hitler así que por qué
usted me va a llamar así
acción de estos hombres en este momento
se tiene que entender en el contexto de
la contraofensiva que planea Ucrania
ellos intentan diversificar la tensión
de las fuerzas rusas y así debilitarlas
para poder hacer ese avance que esperan
hacer en las próximas semanas y meses
para retomar territorio tenemos un
trofeo de verdad logramos tomar algunas
armas también como ametralladoras y esas
cosas así que estoy completamente
satisfecho con el resultado de la
operación